this is the personal cost of Australia's
bushfire crisis two firefighters killed
when their truck overturned after tree
fell onto the road like most of the
thousands of men and women battling
blazes across Australia they were
volunteers who put their lives at risk
to keep others safe we do need to honor
these men and recognise that there is
there is no finer person available in my
view than someone that is willing to put
themselves on the line for the want of
nothing in return no remuneration no
nothing but other than to simply make a
positive difference in their local
community across their home city in
Sydney flags flew at half-mast we can't
express enough our deepest deepest
sympathy and condolences to their loved
ones obviously still in shock as to
what's occurred and these two brave
young men who lost their lives represent
for us the thousands and thousands of
volunteers on the ground bush fires have
been burning across Australia for months
but this week the combination of heat
waves and strong winds is making the
situation even more volatile more than a
hundred fires are burning in Australia's
most populous state of New South Wales
where dozens of homes have been
destroyed as an environmental crisis
unfolds the Prime Minister found himself
facing heat over his decision to take a
holiday to Hawaii this week many
questioned the appropriateness of the
leader going on vacation when large
parts of the country are on fire he told
a Sydney radio station the holiday was
planned before the fires began because
they have been such horrendous events
that that as that has understandably
caused a lot of anxiety and I deeply
regret
he's been forced to return home as the
situation gets even worse authorities
are warning the fire danger is reaching
catastrophic levels
Jessica Washington al Jazeera Sydney